okay jaco your reaction to marsoc
right marsala mar soc
forming marine corps special operations
command
yeah so that's a new a new thing um
so and this is the question that he's
asking so
marines think that they're seals now or
yeah we should be or we should have been
marines all along
so this is a question about like i said
the marine corps special operations
command it was
formed in i don't know 2005
2006 maybe
um and and if you don't know the army
has
its own special operations group the
navy has its own special operations
group the air force has its own special
operations group and the marine corps
did not
what is force recon have you ever yeah
force recon was
a part of the marine corps but it wasn't
broken off
and and it didn't get the extra money
and the extra funding and it didn't fall
under the chain of command
of special operations and so when they
made marsoc
it did so now they took a bunch of the
forced recon guys
and put them into a group and have their
own funding and everything else so
the bottom line is on this
is that the marine corps is awesome and
i love the marine corps
and i think that this was long overdue i
think that
the marine corps as a whole
is likely
it's likely the most capable
fighting unit the world has ever known
to be honest with you i mean maybe the
in addition the airborne divisions from
the army are also
just highly capable but
the marine corps with its air ground sea
it's got command and control it's got
integrated intelligence it's got
everything and it can use it all
together and so that makes it just an
extremely
effective and efficient fighting force
and they are highly disciplined they are
highly motivated there's an incredible
esprit de corps
so for me this was long overdue
and i think that i actually did a
turnover with the with the initial kind
of marsoc
group in 2004 in baghdad
and i had worked with the marine corps
on i'd worked with forest recon on
multiple deployments when i was a
younger seal
and they took a bunch of those guys a
bunch of just legendary
forest recon guys and put them into this
first
marsoc company and they were awesome
awesome warriors awesome guys
and i think they actually have one thing
that that's a huge benefit to them
is in the marine corps you're in the
marine corps so every marine corps
every marine is a rifleman they have the
opportunity to work with big
conventional infantry companies and
platoons
and battalions so so their guys will be
very experienced
and i think that they are going to be
i mean i think that the marine corps
special operations command is going to
be an extremely
capable force in the future and
i am glad
to say the least that they will be
defending
our country and freedom
around the world for many many years to
come
yeah that kind of goes along with what
how you were saying or
a lot of these points that these books
make about how the discipline and the
training are so paramount you know and
success
now you have yet another division that's
gonna get some
solid training you know yeah for sure
there's no doubt the marine corps will
put these guys through
outstanding training yeah